alors d'abord il ne faut pas confondre
les chimères laisser le sushi ps enfin
tout cela est un peu compliquée pour les
auditeurs sûrement évidemment on nous
dit que c'est pour les greffes d'organes
et ça permet d'en avoir
sur quoi il faut être vigilant c'est
pour toujours les abus possibles les
dérives possibles parce que parce que
l'homme reste l'homme qu'on voit bien
qu'on est dans une mondialisation qu'il
ya toujours un pays qui est plus malin
que l'autre et qui voudra faire ce que
l'autre interdit et on entend encore une
et surtout rennes
notre à porter là dans l'hémicycle qui
nous dit mais ça se fait ailleurs et les
autres pays le font et donc à partir non
les autres pays le font et bien voilà on
finit par y aller parce que on est
presque obligé ce contre quoi je m'élève
parce que c'est pas parce que les autres
pays le flanc dont on doit réfléchir on
doit être libre on doit discerner on
doit nous faire ce qu'on veut à faire
forcément ce que les autres pays font
donc je veux qu'on reste vigilant là
dessus
bien sûr c'est pour la recherche bien
sûr ça permet de faire des greffes
bien sûr ça peut être un plus mais je
m'oppose aux dérives possibles et et aux
abus possibles
il faut bien bien encadré et bien de
surveiller effectivement être vigilant à
tout et on ne peut pas on peut pas
savoir ce qui va se passer dans vingt
ans dans trois ans donc on ne peut pas
prévoir aujourd'hui est donc facile de
précaution vaut là dessus comme sur le
reste alors le problème des chimères que
ce soit pour fabriquer des organes plus
facilement et on est en pénurie
d'organes depuis toujours ou à des fins
de recherche ça n'est qu'une des
composantes de la révolution
biotechnologiques à l'oeuvre et oui il y
a des problèmes philosophiques et
politiques majeurs jeux sont
bouleversants mais les chimères ne sont
pas un enjeu plus bouleversants de mon
point de vue que la sélection
embryonnaire qui arrive à grands pas les
bébés à la carte
la pma qui ne fait que commencer et puis
également les dispositifs neurologiques
comme les implants ne ralink qu'ellen
mosque le fondateur d automobile tesla
et homme le plus riche du monde est en
train de développer qu'il a l'intention
de mettre dans le cerveau
des gens dans les décennies qui viennent
pour les malades mais aussi chez les non
malades de manière à augmenter leurs
capacités intellectuelles et musique
donc oui la réflexion doit être menée et
les chimères ça n'est qu'un tout petit
bout de l'ensemble des enjeux liés aux
technologies démiurgique qu'on appelle
les technologies ntic et je suis
d'accord avec madame utile de passer de
l'homme 1.0 à l'homme augmenté 2.0 c'est
vertigineux et il faut une réflexion
politique sur ces sujets là je crois que
le temps humain que le temps de l'homme
n'est pas forcément prêt il ne va pas
aussi vite et en tout cas ça peut être
une cause de division de la société
parce qu'il ya ceux qui vont très vite
et qui sont toutes afin qu'ils courent
très vite qu'ils sont up qui sont comme
le dr alexandre se combinant conscient
de tout ça et même qu'ils approuvent qui
court avec hey hey hey ya les autres qui
sont pas du tout dans le train et nous
en tant que politique
on doit rassembler tout le monde une
bonne politique est au service de la
paix on peut pas si on continue à comme
ça segmente arisée les uns les autres et
il faudrait il faut arriver à concilier
tout le monde et je suis d'accord ça
devient compliqué parce que on fabrique
mondialement une société où
effectivement on laisse les uns courir
très vite et je ne veux pas qu'on laisse
les autres sur le bord de la route
aujourd'hui nous avons tous les six mois
des innovations technologiques
bouleversante et notre régulation techno
politique c'est-à-dire de l'interface
entre la technique et la politique elle
n'est pas adaptée
on voit bien la difficulté de réguler
des technologies qui galope avec des
procédures qui sont très lentes et avec
une opinion qui ne suis pas donc la
discussion politique elle est rendue
difficile parce que la technologie
galope à une vitesse folle et ça va
encore s'aggraver dans les décennies qui
viennent et puis parce que l'opinion ne
peut pas comprendre des sujets qui
aujourd'hui sont devenus tellement
compliqué donc on a aujourd'hui un une
vraie limitation de notre réflexion
bioéthique et moi je suis plutôt un bios
progressiste mais je milite pour le
débat et je comprends tout à fait que
les
jeu dont on parle soi bouleversant pour
les croyants mais pas uniquement pour
les croyants moi personnellement je suis
athée mais je suis convaincu que ces
enjeux sont bouleversants et je me pose
plein de questions sur l'émergence de
l'homme dieu dotée des pouvoirs des murs
gic des nouvelles technologies donc ces
enjeux vertigineux il faut qu'on ait une
technologie politique pour pouvoir en
discuter pour pouvoir éviter
l'apparition d'une société à deux
vitesses parce que très clairement vont
se poser des vraies questions dans
l'accès à ces technologies
donc il est urgent que la politique soit
de plus en plus une techno politique
intégrant tous ces enjeux éthiques de la
technologie et je trouve qu'on y
travaille pas assez
je trouve que la réflexion autour de la
loi bioéthique a été bâclée a été n'a
pas été aussi intense qu'elle aurait dû
être qu'il faudrait une réflexion
associant davantage la population